bonjour à tous et l'air de par le break
de leur faire l'actualité politique et
parlementaire de la semaine aux 45
minutes avec quatre villes d'hérat mais
côté moujan katia toujours dit qu'elle
est dans l'actu cette semaine le
positionnement de l'ump face au front
national qui suscite rom ou les
fractures après la législative partielle
dans le doubs de longs débats la droite
appelle soit s'abstenir soit voter blanc
alain juppé nicolas sarkozy ne sont pas
sur la même longueur d'onde les
primaires de 2007 serait déjà dans
toutes les têtes et on parlera de la loi
macron l'examen se poursuit à
l'assemblée nationale sur fond de
polémique cette semaine le ministre de
l'économie a révélé qu'il avait reçu des
menaces de mort de la part d'officiers
des professions réglementées il a aussi
reconnu dans le même temps s'être trompé
sur certains aspects de son projet le
plus de lait d'autres soupçons et
révélations plongée au coeur de la
machination politico financière
clearstream vous en rappelez
certainement révélée par le journaliste
denis robert en 2001 la faire des
affaires comme on l'a appelée fait
l'objet d'un film
ça sort dans quelques jours sur vos
écrans et pour commenter cette semaine
chargée notre invité rachida dati
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation êtes députée européenne maire
du 7e arrondissement de paris vous avez
été garde des sceaux avant de réagir à
l'actualité
c'est la tradition dans cette émission
je vous propose d'écouter ce que pensent
de vous certains députés de droite comme
de gauche d'ailleurs écouter les plus
conséquents des plus républicaine quinze
tombes de responsables sa propre famille
politique et donc de ce point de vue là
je lui rends grâce le contribué à donner
un peu d'oxygène et un peu le caractère
un peu salubre au débat qui a tendance à
déraper de temps en temps une femme
dynamique qui a pas sa langue dans la
poche s'est dit les choses comme on a
envie de les lire
là elle a aidé nicolas sarkozy dé
manière considérable tout à fait en 2007
au début de
son premier mandat et elle a fait un
travail qui est assez remarquable au
niveau de la justice l'a refait la carte
judiciaire est là elle a eu beaucoup de
courage à l'époque je trouve qu'elle a
une qualité considérable qu'elle a
combattu vitter la pugnacité ce qu'est
toujours tout à fait important politique
il est un peu dommage qu'au fond elle
soit laissé à l'écart actuellement par
sa propre famille politique
au bénéfice d'autres personnes qui n'ont
pas nécessairement le même talent moi je
que je crois c'est que c'était un gars
des shows courageux qui a entrepris une
une courageuse réforme de la carte
judiciaire ce qui était pas facile et
c'est une femme de conviction fidèle en
amitié et fidèle dans ses idées et un
exemple de ce qu'est le travail fait par
l'école de la république et y en a plein
d'autres à ce niveau là des gens partis
vraiment du bas de l'échelle sociale
pour arriver par leur travail tout en
haut
si une étoile filante que c'est un peu
ternie mais elle aime bien être présente
dans le débat politique puisque elle est
toujours sur les angulation et j'ai vu
d'ailleurs qu'elle reprenait encore
appeler le service serait déçu
certainement d'ailleurs de ne pas avoir
été retenu par nicolas sarkozy dans son
équipe rapprochée
alors justement rachida dati vous qui
avez été au coeur de réacteur de toutes
les campagnes est ce que vous n'avez pas
quelques regrets
finalement de te laisser en dehors de la
reconstruction c'est à dire de gagner
c'est ce que d'abord ce que je trouve
ces droites et gauches les personnalités
vous avez interrogé
moi c'est ce que j'ai aimé ce que j'aime
dans la politique c'est effectivement de
pouvoir débattre sans 100 m dans des
affrontements stériles ou même d'une
violence inouïe
là ce que j'ai pu dire oui mais et j'ai
travaillé tout avec l'ensemble de ses
parlementaires
et c'est vrai qu'on a des points communs
ce qu on a extrêmement républicain et
puis on qu'on défend parce que soit
pascal cherki ou ou même
monsieur charles lindbergh c'est vrai
que ce sont des personnalités qui ont
des vraies convictions et qui sont des
vrais républicains moi je sais qu'on a
eu des débats vraiment extrêmement
positif et qui m'encourage en tous les
cas dans combat politique
ensuite de 10 un petit peu à l'écart où
l'entente du doigt alors pas du tout
parce que je les dis des roses une
interview évidemment je vois nicolas
sarkozy très régulièrement
il m'a proposé d'intégrer l'organigramme
d'ailleurs aimé proposer des délégué
général aux questions de sécurité
d'avoir même l'imam ou demander même ce
que je souhaitais et même à quel niveau
je souhaitais mettre dans l'organigramme
j'ai refusé voilà donc je les dis j'ai
pas d'amertume ni aigreur je trouve
simplement que d'être dans
l'organigramme là à mon sens je trouvais
que ça et uniquement sur les questions
de sécurité
sam enfermés ou sa restreignait le débat
et moi je voulais quelque chose qui peut
plus large
non non pas du tout ça n'a rien à voir
mais c'est marrant vous c'est vous qui
fermait jaune non le mac
j'ai dit à nicolas sarkozy que je le
soutenais que j'étais effectivement je
défends dès que je défende effectivement
ces combats et je le soutiens dans dans
son travail pas facile au près dans
l'ump
pour autant je ne souhaitais pas
m'enfermer dans dans une chez nous un
organigramme parce que je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui le débat que nous avons
en france et l'état de la france exige
que nous soyons effectivement moi je
considère un peu sur tous les fronts un
peu sur tous les sujets et d'être au
premier rang de tous les combats c'est
pas dit non c'est pas l'histoire de
liberté du tout puisque si c'était le
cas je le dirai ça n'est pas ça c'est de
pouvoir aborder tous les sujets d'être
de tous les tous les combats et tous les
débats sur toutes les questions
c'est vrai que si vous êtes sur les
questions de sécurité c'est plus
compliqué de d'aborder les questions
d'éducation les questions d'équité et de
justice
donc oui ça a été d'ailleurs j'ai revu
encore asséné alain colas sarkozy qui
m'a redemandé non sais c'est que points
je considère je suis à ma place à droite
je suis à ma place à l'ump - raser sur
le point de tout et les combats et jeu
ailleurs et je suis entre je vais en
france soutenir d'ailleurs nos candidats
aux élections départementales
donc je fais pleinement partie de cette
famille politique
et contrairement aux derniers
intervenants je ne suis pas du tout
qu'on vous a deux et ça non mais je
trouve d'ailleurs regardez vos
l'actualité est riche et les sujets
fondamentaux sont très riendeau et notre
famille politique doit se positionner
sur tous ces sujets justement je vous
propose de parler de la loi macro et de
tout le pataquès cumul qui a eu dans
l'hémicycle le ministre lui joue la
transparence
le coeur du texte c'est la réforme des
professions réglementées le ministre de
l'économie a fait son mea culpa il sait
il a reconnu s'être trompé sur la
question de la baisse des tarifs des
notaires et au même moment il révélait
aussi une existence de menaces de mort
je propose d'y voir plus clair avec elsa
monde à gaza et maxence cani c'est l'un
des volets les plus explosifs de la loi
macron la réforme des professions
réglementées
une mesure attaqué de toutes parts et
surtout par les notaires eux mêmes qui
n'ont pas hésité à mener une campagne de
lobbying est annoncée 15000 destructions
d'emplois ils ont provoqué la colère des
manuels macro je n'accepte pas comme
argument des chiffres qui de manière
scandaleuse ont été mises en avant par
certains professionnels sans aucun
fondement sans aucune preuve et sans
aucun sérieux je ne fais honnêtement
même pas référence aux menaces de mort
j'ai porté plaintes que j'ai reçues de
certains officiers publics et
ministériels parce que vous m'accorderez
sur le fait que c'est particulièrement
étonnant le gouvernement revient
toutefois sur l'une des mesures
critiquées
le corridor tarifaire à la place il
instaure un système de remise sur les
tarifs et emmanuel macron vais même
jusqu'à faire son mea culpa
alors j'en finirai par le corridor
tarifaire est là en plaidant coupable en
quelque sorte puisque c'est moi même qui
est introduit cette subtilité
pourquoi je vais être là très
transparent parce que avec la même
conviction que j'ai pour défendre ce en
quoi je crois j'ai la même lucidité
je me suis trompé insuffisant pour
l'opposition qui ne croient pas aux
effets de ces annonces jusqu'ici on ne
parlait de croissance et d'activité
le maître mot aujourd'hui c'est
transparence alors cette transparence
vous l'avez fait finalement avec une
certaine sincérité puisque vous avez
reconnu votre erreur faute avouée à
moitié pardonnée
il ne vous reste plus qu'à balayer de ce
qui reste de scories dans les
professions réglementées et nous serons
d'accord et peut-être même que vous
aurez des gens de l'ump pour voter votre
loi ça pourrait être consensuel les
articles suivants s'attaque au volet sur
la liberté d'installation
l'un des autres points très contestée
par l'opposition qui y voient un risque
de désertification juridique alors sur
cette affaire d' excuses présentées dans
l'hémicycle emmanuel macron a donc fait
son mea culpa ce que pour vous c'est un
aveu de faiblesse ou au contraire un
acte de courage
moi je trouve que au delà des
divergences que nous avons politiquement
et compris avec emmanuel macron je
trouve que c'est quand même un homme
moi je trouve deux de grande qualité
avec une grande lucidité et moi je
trouve très courageux et je trouve que
quand on dit le courage en politique on
nous demande pas d'être courageux moment
d'être responsable il est à la fois
courageux et responsable
et moi je trouve que cette loi dans
lequel effectivement il ya aussi des
faiblesses dans ce oui parce qu'il ya
beaucoup
il ya beaucoup de choses et des choses
parfois même très différentes mais quand
il dit je reconnais m'être trompé je
vous renvoie une nuit à très peu
d'hommes ou de femmes politiques qui
reconnaît s'être trompé même quand c'est
le cas donc voulu accorder cela parce
qu'il aurait très bien pu dire le texte
reportant le texte et leur nom ils
auraient pu dire aussi voilà nous sommes
arrivés à un autre type de compromis le
débat parlementaire enrichi ce texte
il reconnaît s'être trompé donc faut lui
reconnaître cette intelligence là parce
que je sais quand même c'est comme de
l'intelligence et donc sur les gens
posaient cela c'est vrai que les menaces
de mort ça fait pas partie d'une
démocratie de l'état de droit
le débat de la démocratie exige vu des
balles et des discussions mais pas les
menaces de mort n'était pas digne de
notre république il y avait beaucoup de
choses à cette loi est un petit peu
moins maintenant qu'est-ce que vous
retenez au final sachant que bruxelles
avait donné une somme satisfecit sur
cette loi aujourd'hui on risque encore
de se faire taper sur les doigts
non mais sur ces plans si je reprends
pour les professions réglementées de
dire qu'il est important de réformes et
des professions qui qui bénéficié de ne
pas dire de d'un statut particulier ou
d'un statut à part d'autres les notaires
les vicitmes les avocats qu'il faille
réformer évoluer adapter ces professions
à l'évolution de la société
tout le monde est d'accord y compris les
professions réglementées elle-même pour
avoir travaillé avec eux il ya peut-être
des spécificités qu'on nous devons
garder et que nous vous devons garder
qui sont très française et qui peut qui
d'ailleurs pour les notaires dans en
europe on s'en inspire
pourquoi parce que les notaires ce n'est
pas ce n'est une se bat pas pour garder
un privilège il faut s'intéresser à la
nature même de ces professions c'est une
profession qui protège notamment dans
certains cas les plus vulnérables les
plus modestes ceux qui n'ont pas
qui ne m'ont pas forcément facilement
accès au droit où est la justice
moi les notaires on oublie que d'abord
c'est une profession qui permet et un
vrai maillage territorial et notamment
dans les territoires ruraux
le notaire c'est un interlocuteur
important c'est un auxiliaire de justice
et donc c'est important aussi notamment
pour les personnes âgées et personnes
dépendantes les personnes un peu en
difficulté
le notaire est importante à se lâcher
avec les notaires ne sais pas ça chez ça
n'a rien à voir c'est de dire est ce
qu'on veut garder encore une profession
qui est un auxiliaire de justice qui
permet aussi de protéger qui est partout
présent sur le territoire national même
dans des endroits où plus personne ne
veut aller s'installer
justement comme on leur impose une
installation dont ils sont dans des
endroits reculés
il peut aussi le protège des personnes
qui souvent sont en difficulté ou
vulnérables donc je trouve que le
compromis qui a été trouvé dans la
statue sera pas fait au mardi tous les
regards se tournent vers votre parti
vers l'ump une défaite le dimanche et
voilà le parti au bord de l'explosion ce
pas moi qui le dit c'est dixit nicolas
sarkozy en cause des différentes
positions des dirigeants vis-à-vis du
duel entre le front national et le parti
socialiste
on voit cela avec julie andrieu après
plus de deux heures de bureau politique
l'ump a choisi de ne pas choisir
dimanche prochain dans le doubs entre le
parti socialiste et le front national
avec 22 voix contre 19 la position
officielle de l'ump
c'est finalement l'abstention ou le vote
blanc on revient au ni ni qui avait été
adoptée dans le passé que nicolas
sarkozy avait lui-même d'ailleurs
suggéré il souhaitait aller un peu plus
loin pour tenir compte notamment des
positions dans l'ain juppé ou de
nathalie kosciusko morizet cette
position de synthèse
n'a pas recueilli la majorité des voix
ce soir une majorité des membres du
bureau politique ont préféré s'en tenir
au ni ni
c'est désormais la position de l'ump
nous allons tous nous y tenir pourtant
chacun garde sa position près de l'autre
moitié du bureau politique aurait
préféré une évolution avec une
opposition claire au front national tout
en laissant le libre choix aux électeurs
la position personnelle d'alain juppé va
plus loin c'est un barrage clair au
front national or ce que je dis et c'est
là qu'il peut y avoir une différence
comment arriver au résultat que nous
voulons atteindre c'est à dire éviter
l'élection de sept députés du front
national il ya là une divergence
certains disent en s'abstenant
et moi je dis il faut peut-être aller
dans ce cas de figure là jusqu'au vote
pour le candidat qui l'a combat mais la
ligne officielle du parti est actée pour
la législative partielle dans le but si
les électeurs suivent la consignes
nationales ils ne choisiront pas une
situation intenable l'avenir pour la
numéro deux du parti
il y avait vraiment des deux de type de
position quoi c'était quasiment moitié
moitié dans le bureau politique et je
pense qu'à l'avenir sur sur cette
question importante qui ait tranché pour
l'élection législative du doubs dimanche
mais qui pourra se reposer en d'autres
occasions il faudra il faudra un jour
consultez nos militants tout cas moi
c'est ma ses mains c'est ce que je crois
le débat est loin d'être clos
il faudra définir la stratégie politique
de l'ump pour les élections
départementales
rachida dati était le ni ni qui a gagné
ce que c'était une position que vous
soutenez faut je peux pas vous dire
c'est pas la bonne question le sujet
était effectivement suite à cette
législative partielle qui nous a surpris
sur le nom les résultats faut aussi le
reconnaître qu'ils ont été les gagnants
de cette et les législatives partielles
ont l'impression que tout le monde se
focalise en dix ans le front national
non c'est d'abord l'abstention
moi je m'interroge aujourd'hui pourquoi
notre électorat ne se mobilisent plus
pourquoi les français se détournent
maintenant de la politique aussi bien
pour le parti socialiste que pour le
front national il n'y a pas non plus une
déferlante front national il ya une
déferlante abstentionnistes donc ça veut
dire que nous
on apporte pas non plus les bonnes
solutions on n'apporte pas les bonnes
réponses dès que votre parti quand vous
dites quelque chose mais plus entendu
parler vous proposez journaux mais c'est
pas sûr la solution c'est de dire
aujourd'hui
- mon interrogation et c'est ce que
j'essaye de faire parler des placements
que je fais parler soutien au candidat
que nous avons dans dans l'épreuve pour
les prochaines échéances c'est qu'est ce
que nous proposons aux français
aujourd'hui et en particulier nos
électeurs dans le programme dans notre
ligne politique dans notre identité donc
aujourd'hui les français et les
électeurs ne vont pas voter
ensuite quand tu es pour le peu qu'ils
votent ca votent front national
donc ça doit nous interpeller nous
interroger donc on ne peut pas dire non
non non on veut comme senna mais on peut
peut être faire comme si de rien était
de dire ça vaut de plus où ça vote fn et
donc il faut faire une petite
combinaisons politiciennes
à lyon nous au parti socialiste pour
faire barrage à un peu de gens qui
votent encore et qui votent fn s'est
classé au républicain ça ne fonctionne
pas non mais le front républicain c'est
de dire à une partie des français qui
vous quand même qu'ils se déplacent pour
aller voter et qui votent front national
cirque où ça vaut de plus donc font
romeu dire aux gens qui ne votent pas
d'aller volter et ceux qui votent ils
votent nous front national d'oka ils se
déplacent pour aller exprimer
un choix politique il ya ces gens l'ordi
façon si vous vous déplacez pas on s'en
fiche plus pour ceux qui se déplacent où
on va être totalement sourd à votre à
votre choix donc ça n'est pas possible
que la position de l'egypte et de
nathalie kosciusko morizet est
impossible a tonné me nommer c'est moi
je sais pas c'est de dire si on a ses
positions pour argumenter
c'est de dire alors aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on 10 pouces on sait c'est
grave ce qui se passe
vous venez plus voter pour nous vous ne
votez pas ici non plus quand vous
déplacez vous allez au fn donc on a
compris
voilà ce qu'on vous propose et donc on
est on vous propose en attendant qu'on
nous fassions mieux de voter si ou ça
mais c'est parce que nous en ce moment
on leur dit on leur dit ce que vous
faites est pas bien
alors maintenant vous allez voter pour
le ps parce qu'on veut pas du front
national je la mauvaise méthode que ça
qu'on n'écoute pas assez que le ipad et
coûte pas bien sûr
vié sur le sujet il est là le sujet
assure qu' on en train de traiter la
conséquence on traite pas du tout la
cause moi je voudrais savoir aujourd'hui
pourquoi notre électorat n'est pas allés
voter
pourquoi les français ne vont plus voter
et pourquoi le peu qu'ils se déplacent
vote pour le front national
moi elle est là ma préoccupation parce
qu'on peut pas faire comme si ceux qui
se sont déplacés n'ont pas voté front
national
et là ce que ce qui se passe qui s'est
passé au bureau politique c'est qu'on
n'était plus sûr pourquoi ça vous n'êtes
pas ou pourquoi sa beauté fait c'est de
dire on ne veut pas du fn et dont les
autres ouvriers ecosoc ont voté fn a
finalement ça compte pas parce que quoi
que vous fassiez l'on ne vous entendra
jamais ça n'est pas responsable et
chance est responsable aussi de dire
abstentions c'est pour ça que je vous
dit vous êtes en train de parler
politique dont il s'agit c'est pas dû
dire abstention c'est qu'est ce qu'on
propose à vos robots abstentions je
termine juste sur cydia abstention mais
on dit pas avant moi je sais ce qu'ils
vont dire on est surpris
excusez nous on vous a pas entendu vous
a pas compris pour l'instant ne votez
pas et on va vous proposer ça mais pour
l'instant on n'a rien proposé du tout
donc c'est irresponsable de dire
abstention à des gens qui sont fruits
moi je connais bien cette région parce
que je suis n'est pas loin c'est une
région qui chauffe de qui souffre du
chômage de la pauvreté des inégalités on
va leur dire la trêve au chaud à paris
natura studio ou dans un bureau
politique entre gens qui effectivement
on se connaît tous de dire c'est pas
bien ce qu'ils ont fait les électeurs
dans le dos et franchement ton pour sa
part c'est pas bien
et puis là on va leur dire c'est
tellement pas volent pas bien ce qu'ont
voté front national
vraiment vous c'est vraiment pas bien
puis ce qu'on pas voter vous c'est
encore pire
donc la prochaine fois comme ne veut pas
nous nous nous on veut pas du front
national où on veut pas du parti social
surtout n'allez pas voter donc le sujet
il n'est pas de dire faut pas voter ou
faut voter parti socialiste le sujet
c'est de dire pourquoi on en est arrivé
là
pourquoi donc on sait que vous voyez que
je suis obsédé abandonné il faut
proposer des choses à nos électeurs
rappeler qu'elle est notre vertébrale
très laid notre identité et quelles sont
vos valeurs
et ensuite on peut donner une consigne
de postions très rapide justement pour
les départementales cesser demain la
départementale est ce que pour vous il
faut consulter ce que l'ump doit
consulter les militants parce que c'est
ce que cette ligne est bien sûr serre
sur ses consignes de vote a donné ce que
si nous les militants sur une une
consigne de vote
on consulte à limiter des militants sur
des sujets de société sur des sur nos
valeurs sur la ligne du parti
moi je veux qu'on consulter les
militants sur un projet de fou pour une
ambition pour la france on consulte pas
les militants pour dire c'est vrai aussi
c'est non c'est enfin c'est pas le rôle
de la consultation la consultation aller
sur le pour le fond elle est pas sûr sur
la conséquence d'un mauvais vote c'est
comme si on disait on a perdu mais en
fait on veut maintenant c'est on n'a pas
perdu deux mois le savez dans ce
débat-là me gêne ce qui me gêne ce qui
moi me choque profondément
ça veut dire moi des personnes soûles
est pourquoi nos électeurs ne se sont
pas mobilisés
samak alors de deux questions qui se
posent en france on va parler de
l'actualité à mardi toujours avec cette
nouvelle attaque terroriste à nice
contre trois militaires en faction
devant un centre communautaire juif
l'agresseur moussa coulibaly a été
arrêté sur place bernard cazeneuve a
évoqué quelques mesures écouter
personnage qui a cherché à atteindre et
il faut le dire à assassiner des
militaires aujourd'hui à nice tu est un
personnage qui avait donné des signes de
radicalisation détectée par le service
du renseignement territoriale du
ministère de l'intérieur qui avait saisi
la direction générale de la sécurité
intérieure ce qui avait permis
d'ailleurs de suivre un certain nombre
de ses déplacements est de constater
qu'il s'était rendu en turquie de
pouvoir ainsi demander son retour en
france et de l'auditionner au sein des
services de la direction générale de la
sécurité intérieure
rachida dati bernard cazeneuve évoque un
terrorisme en libre accès est ce que
pour vous c'est le mot juste qu'il a
raison bernard cazeneuve a tout à fait
les mots justes pour le libre accès
c'est qu'avant effectivement dans les
groupes terroristes ou de criminalité
organisée
c'était très structurée des
organisations si on passe à l'action
directe les brigades rouges ou même le
terrain ce sont des groupes structurés
ils des olo gizeh traçable aujourd'hui
quelqu'un peut se radicalise et sur
internet
il regarde une vidéo lendemain 10 prend
une arme et il peut commettre encore moi
j'ai jamais été sur cette thèse ce
qu'ont développé cette thèse notamment
un ancien patron du renseignement
d'ailleurs les actualités de montre
qu'il avait tort il n'y a pas à l'ère
d'internet il n'y a plus de
l'observateur tout le monde est connecté
ou être connecté avec une vidéo du bout
du monde avec votre voisin
donc il n'y a pas de loup solitaire donc
c'est vrai que ce terrorisme est pour la
traçabilité pour la prévention pour
l'anticipation c'est très compliqué
c'est vraiment très compliqué donc c'est
pour ça que la formule est tout à fait
adapté alors on passe à mercredi et je
vous propose de parler un peu d'europe
avec la visite d'un ministre d'un
premier ministre grec à paris
il est venu chercher le soutien de la
france
alexis tsipras ce le nouveau premier
ministre grec s'est montrée aux côtés de
françois hollande il tente d'obtenir un
allègement du fardeau de la dette
grecque plus de 315 milliards d'euros
bras de fer en vue explications avec
louis sybille fini la campagne
électorale le ton n'est plus le même
alexis tsipras ce noeud tempête plus
contre les technocrates européens
le maître mot pour alléger le fardeau de
la dette grecque c'est la négociation
le premier ministre grec se veut
réaliste la dette doit être viable doit
devenir viable c'est quelque chose dont
on discute
l'avenir européen et notre avenir commun
et nous devons sortir de cette crise qui
s'autoalimente françois hollande a
rappelé les engagements pris par l'état
grec mais reste ouvert à des solutions
saas et l'objectif trouver un accord
c'est à dire de définir un cadre
économique que financier contractuelles
entre l'europe et la grèce et c'est ce à
quoi la france a dit sa disponibilité
rome paris bruxelles c'est un marathon
diplomatique auquel se livrent alexis
tsipras ce depuis le début de la semaine
une opération séduction
je promets je porterai une cravate quand
nous aurons trouvé une solution commune
et viable pour l'europe
très peu d'annoncés pour l'instant tout
se joue en coulisses comme ici dans les
bureaux de la bce
objectif obtenir de l'argent des
liquidités une des pistes indexé le
remboursement de la dette à la
croissance du pays
celle ci s'envole au dessus des 300
milliards d'euros la grèce doit par
exemple 40 milliards d'euros à la france
alors la situation cette affaire grave
et avec la décision de la banque
centrale européenne donne plus
refinancer certaines banques grecques
aux conditions aussi avantageuses que
jusqu alors est-ce que vous pensez que
ça peut déboucher sur une nouvelle crise
grave en zone euro voire la nuit
c'est pareil sentiment je n'y crois pas
je pense pas une aggravation je pense
que le premier ministre grec tiendra les
engagements européens
maintenant qu'il demande un peu d'air
c'est légitime faut quand même rappeler
que le déficit grec s'est beaucoup
réduit c'est vrai que ses prédécesseurs
ont fait le boulot la preuve c'est
qu'ils nous donnent la chair de dans les
zones humides ont fait le boulot faut
quand même il ya eu quelques raisons
mais son discours est évidemment mais
c'est pas on n'est pas pour connaître
par exemple le mouvement podemos ans en
espagne c'est pas du tout les mêmes
dirigeants ils sont pas du tout sur la
même ligne ils n'ont pas la même
expérience pas le même parcours mais le
premier ministre grec
de tout façon tiendrons les engagements
il demande un peu d'air il demande un
peu d'ajustements
mais il ne demande pas des annulations
ce que j'ai vu en temps il n'a pas
demandé l'annulation de la dette vous te
dire je ne rembourse plus donc
aujourd'hui de faire rembourser ce qu'il
doit rembourser maintenant qu'il demande
un peu d'air je pense qu'on peut c'est
vrai que l'austérité tel qu'on l'a
qualifié a démontré ses limites
donc aujourd'hui je pense qu'il y aura
des ajustements qui seront trouver un
compromis qui sera trouvé mais il n'y
aura pas d'annulation de la dette
c'est irresponsable cyrénaïque ont pris
pour les graines et la grèce doit
continuer notamment ses réformes
profondes notamment sur sur la fiscalité
que d'inciter un peu plus les grecs pour
ne pas dire tous les grecs appellent ils
à leurs impôts il y a un jour de l'ag
sur la fiscalité oui c'est le problème
ça a été le problème pendant longtemps
mais aussi les politiques ont une
responsabilité puisque ce qu'on
présentait les faux comptes ou à la
commission européenne qui soit la
commission européenne barroso en premier
quand accepter que le vin est
responsable aussi la nation n'avait rien
vu alors que c'était quand même si à la
tête bien aux parlementaires avaient les
yeux doux à l'époque donc il ya quelques
années quand il ya eu les faux comptes
qui ont conduit à la dérive des comptes
publics grecs
sire que les réseaux politiques de
l'époque n'ont pas été n'ont pas été ni
poursuivi n'est apte à qui on l'aura
on leur a rien demandé on l'appelle
demandé aucun compte et à la commission
européenne ce qui ont validé les comptes
présentés on leur a pas demandé de
contre non plus et après ils sont du
compte que les comptes étaient faux et
on leur ait demandé aucun compte que
ils sont rendus compte que les comptes
étaient faux pas de sanction plus
prononcée alors que la commission
pouvait prononcer les sanctions à
l'égard des réseaux à politique grec de
l'époque ils n'ont pas fait donc la
commission européenne a été complice des
responsables politiques grecs de
l'époque
donc c'est facile de faire traquer le
peuple après donc maintenant les
réformes sont mises en place
il faudra aller plus loin sur les
réformes grecques mais il y à haute
il est hors de passion il est hors de
question que la grèce que de la grèce ne
paye pas ses dettes
voilà faisant de gym jarrassé qui nous a
toujours chef du site
le scan de scan du figaro c'est la loupe
du scan à notre partenaire le scan
politique du figaro dimur va commencer
cette semaine qu'un marc parent et
nicolas sarkozy eh oui encore on l'a
appris hier dans marianne
c'était lundi alors que le candidat ump
charles demouge venait d'être battu dans
le doubs nicolas sarkozy était en
conférence à abou dhabi une conférence
rémunérés est ce que c'était vraiment le
bon moment
apparemment s'était fixé de longue date
donc voilà c'est dans le cadre de son
activité privée s'était fixé de longue
date
donc ça n'aurait pas changé le résultat
de la partielle puisque c'était le non
moins depuis que nicolas sarkozy est
arrivé à la tête de l'ump il s'est rendu
deux fois en conférence rémunérer une
seule fois sur le terrain est-ce qu'il
ya pas un problème à ce niveau là des
telles nature est ce qu est ce qu un
chef un chef de parti doit donner des
conférences rémunérés dans des pays du
golfe comme le font de nombreux restes
soient politiques élus à la différence
d'autres il n'a pas de mandat électif
donc beaucoup de deux parlementaires ou
d'élus ont des activités rémunérées
notamment des conférences
il faudrait demander à d'ailleurs au
niveau du parlement
de nombreux parlementaires donnent des
conférences et des conférences rémunérés
mais nicolas sarkozy n'a pas de mandat
électif il peut effectivement poursuivre
son activité privée voilà on peut se
demander quand même parce que ça l'air
de choquer un petit peu est ce que dans
le cadre de 2017 s'il souhaite être
président ne veut pas dire j'arrête ce
genre de conférence après c'est un choix
très personnel moi la question
ce qui m'interpelle qu'est ce qui choque
le lieu où il fait la conférence
d'autres le pays en a mais est ce que
c'est le lieu
non mais les journalistes c'est toujours
pareil c'est subliminal alors posé la
question dit que par le fait de dire
assez choquant que ce soit vous d'avis
il a fait une conférence à washington
est ce que vous auriez eu la même
réaction alors c'est ça la question
est-ce que cela renvoie pourquoi vous
poser cette question parce que le fait
que abou dhabi zle le pays vient pas
d'arrêter de participer à la coalition
contre l'état islamique est ce que est
ce que c'était le bon moment d'aller
dans ce pays maintenant est ce que c'est
le pays avec lequel nous avons une
rupture diplômés amont pas de rupture
mais bon est-ce que c'est un pays qui
pose un problème avec la france
est-ce que
le président hollande ne reçoit pas le
chef d'état d'abou dhabi je pose la
question qu'est ce qui vous pousse à que
vous maintenant pour verbaliser les
choses quand on dit les conférences
rémunérés sont choquantes est ce que
c'est le pays où est ce que c'est le
fasse qu'il fallait compléter de l'aide
de peut-être alors il faut demander à
tous les élus de ne plus faire de
conférences rémunéré pourrait peut-être
et puis la deuxième chose de dire il ya
des pays interdit peut-être aussi donc
dhabi savons que pose la question
moi je considère que tous les pays avec
lesquels nous avons des relations
diplomatiques des échanges
alors nous avons nous avons quand même
une base militaire extrêmement
importante à abou dhabi est ce que ça
aurait on doit la fermer
la question des analyses est-ce que de
vous fermer la base militaire à abou
diaby mots je vous renvoie sur la
conférence qui était donné par nicolas
sarkozy est ce que finalement c'est pas
une erreur que de refaire des
conférences quand on est chef de parti
et qu'on a peut-être objectif d'être à
jour redevenir président de la
république la question elle est est ce
que quelqu'un qui est chef de parti doit
avoir une activité professionnelle par
ailleurs il est c'est pas un rentier il
travaille il alors comme vous quand il
continuera comme d'autres d'autre part
la maîtrise et de dire où c'est pour
tout le monde pareil ou pas le sujet il
ya deux poids deux mesures
voilà en ce moment on est dans le deux
poids deux mesures vous faut dire c'est
interdit et tout le monde s'y plient où
c'est autorisé tout le monde s'il y va
tout le monde peut le faire s'il le
souhaite mais où je gracie que la
différence entre avec d'autres c'est
qu'il n'a pas de mandat une tiff donc ça
lui laisse ce droit j'ai mon côté j'ai
toujours mis tout ce qui n'est pas payé
comme chef de parti mais c'est aussi le
sujet non mais oui faut moi ce qui me
gêne c'est d'essayer de rendre sulfureux
un sujet qui ne l'est pas alors ou sinon
il faut pas laisser un
un truc des kumm de soupçons c'est de
dire voilà faut poser une très bientôt
vous dire nous ça nous gêne qu'ils
fassent des paies confirme dans tel pays
et après vous dire pourquoi voilà mais
je serais je pense que s'il avait fait
une conférence à washington c'est
vraiment rassembler autant de sujets
l'innovation par la part des
journalistes au moment des attentats
de charlie vous avez signé une tribune
dans le guardian quotidien britannique
vous exerciez les politiques à ne pas
stigmatiser la communauté musulmane
au même moment nicolas sarkozy parlait
lui de garder claret à la civilisation
chaque cd propos que vous n'avez pas
vraiment apprécié les journalistes qui
me posait la question me disais est ce
que c'est une guerre de civilisation
sort d'une civilisation contre une autre
j'ai dit que ce n'est pas une guerre de
civilisation c'est ça les fans de la
blague une guerre d'une civilisation
contre une autre parce que pour moi
dèche où la barbarie
ça n'est pas une civilisation quand on
voit qu'ils sont capables de mettre un
homme dans une cage et dû mettre le feu
et je rappelle que l'homme qui était
dans la cage était un musulman donc que
ces types là qui effectivement se
revendique où vous sous pretexe d'islam
pour commettre leur barbarie
ce ne sont pas des musulmans je vous dis
l'homme le pilote jordanien est un
musulman qui l'ont mis dans une cage
auquel ils ont mis le feu
je crois qu un pas pire comme punch
barbarie donc ça pour moi celle là on ne
peut pas qualifier le terme de
civilisation qui a employé nicolas
sarkozy mais ils avouent chercher nos
élus à 30 secondes je me dis que ça
n'est pas une guerre d'une civilisation
contre une autre parce que de mettre un
homme dans une cage ceux ci voulaient ce
relèvement
c'est pas la civilisation de la barbarie
question contre pour ce corps dont on
vous a vu ce lundi réagir à une
une annonce de nathalie kosciusko
morizet elle était sur bfm ce lundi et
elle y est allé de sa petite anecdote
pour dénoncer la radicalisation la
société on l'écoutait le maire de
mulhouse qui est un ami jean rottner me
dis que dans sa ville il y a des
dizaines d'enfants qui le matin arrive
tous les jours en retard à l'école parce
qu'ils sont à la prière ces propos vous
ont fait réagir dès lundi vous avez
accusé une gamme de diviser les français
ont tout de suite accusé
j'ai dit aqueuse et j'accuse vous avez
vous avez vous avez évoqué vous avez
évoqué la division des français
reprenait mais pas juste prix entre les
internautes y venir ont vérifié vos
propos donc est-ce que j'ai mis g10
j'accuse nathalie kosciusko morizet non
diviser les points de vue vous avez vous
avez évoqué la division des français en
réaction aux propos de natori c'est déjà
plus atténuée certes certes
certes ça veut rien dire ça veut dire
j'ai raison je n'ai pas complet propos
vous avez tenu wenger a fait amende
honorable sur cette question en
expliquant qu'elle avait finalement mal
interprété amende honorable a dit je me
suis trompé
est il donc je présente mes excuses à
ceux que j'ai pour vous gr nous sommes
des récents sa politique est les dents
comme dans un parti qui est un parti
important qui a vocation à gouverner de
nouveau à gouverner un grand pays comme
la corrèze qui est donc on fait très
attention à ce qu'on dit de caen c'est
faux et c'est pour ça que l'avion quand
on prononce des propos qui ne sont pas
vraies là les propos les conséquences
des propos peuvent diviser les français
ça peut attiser des ailes de manière
gratuite
donc en ce moment nous n'avons pas
besoin de ça c'est pour ça que moi
j'avais demandé
j'avais dit nathalie kosciusko morizet
parce qu'on interrogeait le jour même
chalifoux qu'elle s'explique sur ses
propos par ce fléau parce que ça n'était
pas merci merci et on va passer au jeudi
avec le président de la république qui
parle 5ème conférence de presse beaucoup
de questions et un long discours
unité réconciliation ce sont un peu les
maîtres mots de l'intervention du
président de la république pour sa
conférence de presse semestrielle le
chef de l'état a défendu l'esprit du 11
janvier et fait quelques annonces résumé
avec samia déchire rompu à l'exercice
c'est la première fois que le président
démarre par les questions
internationales et d'emblée le ton est
donné
celui d'un message ferme déterminé
presque autoritaire ya un message que je
veux adresser à la communauté
internationale et aux plus grands pays
faites votre travail
une ligne de fermeté qu'il maintient sur
la politique intérieure
mais ce que vous serez un président de
gauche jusqu'à la fin mais je suis
depuis le début françois hollande assume
son pacte de responsabilité et veut
donner l'image d'un homme d'action
je les prends les risques le pouvoir les
prends sur la scène intérieure sur la
scène internationale le rôle d'un chef
d'entreprise je sais que c'est partager
cette prendre des risques c'est
maintenant que vient le moment des
risques qu'il reprend à son compte sur
le chômage toujours aussi élevé le
président mais son mandat dans la
balance un président de la république
n'arrivent pas à atteindre l'objectif
qu'il s'est fixé pour être élu et bien
il ne peut pas être de nouveau candidat
à la responsabilité suprême du pays
françois hollande sait pourtant que le
pari sera bien difficile à tenir en deux
ans et demi
le président a appuyé dans son discours
a évoqué un point important il a dit que
la laïcité n'était pas négociable est ce
que vous le croyez capable d'appliquer
cet axiome est ce qu un président de
gauche peut se montrer inflexible
totalement sur cette question de la
laïcité mais elle est négociable pour
personne elle est dans notre
constitution c'est un principe fondateur
de notre république
c'est ce qui nous permet
à toutes et à tous de vivre elle est
menacée elle est menacée quand ceux qui
sont gardiens de ces principes sont
faibles voilà c'est drôle c'est débat en
disant attention attention c'est que à
un moment donné on a été faibles on a
été peut-être un peu cynique et arrêter
les raisons politiques compris géré
comme tout le monde
tout le monde a eu avec sa petite
lâcheté à un moment donné peut-être pour
pour être élu pour être élu tout court
peut-être pour pour faire plaisir
et maintenant voilà la république c'est
pas négociable parce que c'est notre
notre acte fondateur c'est notre sort
dominant mais le sujet dont mes yeux
rien à modifier notre notre république
et qui est un qui fait notre pays est
fondé sur c'est république est fondée
sur notre constitution qui est vraiment
on est quand même en expliquant
l'exemple dans beaucoup de pays du monde
rien n'est négociable dans nos valeurs
et nos principes à la loi de 1905 dont
tu es une loi très équilibrée qui permet
à toutes et à tous de pouvoir avoir une
religion de ne pas en avoir de pratiquer
son culte ou de ne pas souhaiter une
faut pas user dont il faut il faut pas
toucher à ses principes et ses valeurs
maintenant c'est de dire que c'est pas
négociable effectivement c'est pas
négociable c'est à nous de bien être
solide et ferme sur nos principes et nos
valeurs nous avons eu parfois un peu
faible amo sur françois hollande et la
rue gosset le costume du président élu a
aujourd'hui tout a changé
il est président la république voulait
reconnaître que dans suite aux attentats
du 11 janvier ils feront ces 100 g
derrière lui comme chef de la nation
c'est là où ça démontre que le peuple
français très attachés à nos principes
et nos valeurs et à nos institutions
et c'est vrai que la conférence de
presse hier c'est comment vous dire
c'est un peu compliqué parce qu'on est
encore c'est vrai dans cet esprit du 11
janvier qui doit pas non plus nous nous
endormir ça veut pas dire que tout est
beau l'esprit janvier c'est
effectivement d'être responsable d'être
dans une unité dans l'intérêt du pays
c'est ça qui est intéressant voilà donc
hier il
il a tenu cette conférence de presse
dans cet esprit festif vendu en janvier
ils ont cette qualité prennent
rapidement passé aux plus de l'hebdo
j'imagine que vous vous rappelez bien
sûr de l' affaire clearstream
c'est devenu un film mois dans la sphère
avait été révélée en 2001 par le
journaliste denis robert des révélations
sur les fameux listings controversé sur
fond de guerre politique c'est devenu un
film ça s'appelle l' enquête avec gilles
lellouche sur la semaine prochaine sur
les écrans simon barbarie l'a vu en
avant première
j'ai entendu parler de clearstream
on l'avait presque oublié cette affaire
clearstream
celle révélée par le journaliste denis
robert en 2001 dans son livre révélation
l'enquète son adaptation sur grand écran
réalisé par vincent garenq nous replonge
dans cette affaire symptomatique de
l'argent roi ou la dissimulation de
capitaux le blanchiment d'argent la
corruption sont facilitées et encouragé
par un système de coopérative bancaire
basé au luxembourg est appelé class trim
le scandale financier trouvera son
apothéose lorsque deux hommes politiques
français de premier plan y verront leurs
noms associés
ce qui m'intéressait moi c'est ce
personnage de denis robert et son
enquête parce que j'avais l'impression
qu'avec sarkozy donnait le pain ce qu'on
nous avait raconté en avait plus de sens
et que le grand public l'avait vraiment
pas du tout compris cette histoire
l'enquète c'est aussi l'histoire d'un
homme
le journaliste denis robert incarné par
gilles lellouche ces révélations ne
furent pas sans conséquence pour sa vie
privée soixante trois procédures et 400
visites d'huissiers furent le prix à
payer de sa liberté d'expression
c'était un lanceur dallaire claire de
rien il a et c'est cette thématique de
lancer des alertes ça revient beaucoup
n'en a besoin de gens comme ça mais ces
gens là où encore aujourd'hui se
prennent des procès lorsqu'il a sorti le
son premier livre révélation toute la
campagne promo a été annulé
en l'espace de 48 heures donc évidemment
tous ses collègues journalistes
remettait en cause la véracité de ses
dires de son enquête même le bien fondé
de ce pourquoi il faisait tous ça
vincent garenq et gilles lellouche
réussissent la prouesse de faire de
clearstream un thriller grand public et
passionnant une prouesse pour l'un des
scandales les plus complexes de la vème
république
rachida dati vous avez été ministre de
la justice assem garde des sceaux qu'est
ce qu'il reste de toute cette affaire
clearstream selon vous un film non il ya
aussi le combat de cet homme denis
robert parce que c'est vrai qu'il a été
abîmée dans ses investigations
investigations d'ailleurs le nom de
lanceurs d'alert qu'elle était utilisée
je trouve que je le connais pas mais moi
j'ai toujours puisque j'ai été magistrat
financier donc c'est un des premiers qui
commença pas évoquer les aspects au delà
du blanchiment moi je suis occupé
effectivement deux aspects de
blanchiment dans ma carte
professionnelle
mais il allait au delà parce que hélas
il touchait à quelque chose qui était
pas encore dans la sphère même public
est tel qu'ils étaient les paradis
fiscaux
dire que les paradis fiscaux est à nos
portes à nos portes
et puis et surtout ce qu'il a ce qu'il a
démontré c'est un mécanisme
c'est le mécanisme parce que certains
disent j'aime manger j'ai mis dans ce
sujet me je vais raconte dans ce pays là
mais c'était là on est au delà de
l'optimisation fiscale
c'est de la délinquance et de la
criminalité organisée oui c'est de la
criminalité organisée faut foncer loi
oui mais c'est vrai que son livre était
aussi intéressant et il a été sujet de
beaucoup beaucoup de controverses
beaucoup devraient très vite elle
continue encore merci beaucoup on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine j'aime
mieux mais meurtre est bâti de
programmes sur lcp public sénat